[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing a topic which branches out
from yesterday's video
involving the tri-wizard tournament now
the dry wizard tournament is an integral
part of the harry potter story
as the goblet of fire was the sort of
pivot point
at which voldemort's proper resurgence
was confirmed
after harry traveled to the little
hangalton graveyard peter pettigrew was
able to collect all of the ingredients
necessary
to bring lord voldemort back into his
real form
though the tournament had been around
for hundreds of years and had its fair
share of mishaps through the ages
i'm not sure that anything ever happened
that was quite so bad as to be compared
to the events of the 1994 tournament
where cedric died and the dark lord
voldemort returned
sure people have purportedly died in the
tournament before
but the events of 1994 were dark
sinister so my question is what happened
after 1994
did the tournament continue before we
get started
here's a brief recap on the tournament
from albus dumbledore himself
the triwizard tournament was first
established some 700 years ago
as a friendly competition between the
three largest european schools of
wizardry
hogwarts bobaton and durmstrang a
champion was selected
to represent each school and the three
champions
competed in three magical tasks the
schools took it in turns to host the
tournament
once every five years and it was
generally agreed
to be a most excellent way of
establishing ties between young witches
and wizards
of different nationalities until that is
the death toll mounted so high that the
tournament was discontinued
the tournament dates back 700 years and
ran
uninhibited until the year 1792
at which point a year hiatus was put
forth
due to all three champions being injured
if the tournament stopped for such a
long time
due to injuries surely they cancelled it
after the
cedric died right in my opinion i don't
think that it's very likely that it
continued
the following quote from dumbledore in
the gopita fire suggests that
reinstating the tournament
is not so easy there have been several
attempts over the centuries to reinstate
the tournament
dumbledore continued none of which has
been very successful
however our own departments of
international magical cooperation and
magical games and sports
have decided the time is ripe for
another attempt we have worked hard over
the summer
to ensure that this time no champion
will find himself
or herself in mortal danger however
despite the best efforts of the
departments involved with the
tournament's resurgence
it turns out they weren't able to
prevent people from being injured
killed though in their defense it's hard
to be prepared enough for a resurgence
from the dark lord
given that one of their highest
priorities was making sure that the
tournament was safe
and that they failed in that regard it's
unlikely that the tournament would
continue on
however that's not the only reason in
fact the 94 tournament had a lot of
weird things going on
first of all there was a fourth champion
a 14 year old one with that
this was not supposed to happen and
hogwarts having two representatives is
unfair
to the other institutions the rules
explicitly forbade anyone under 17 from
competing
but here harry was just 14 years old and
the tournament winner this no doubt
would have impacted the interest of both
bobatore
and durmstrang for future tournaments
having the school's greatest champions
bested by
an illegitimate 14 year old participant
is basically just
blatantly disrespectful even if it was
unintentional
not only that but basically everyone
involved with organizing the most recent
tournament
had died mr bagman and mr crouch have
worked tirelessly over the last few
months on the arrangements for the
triwizard tournament
dumbledore continued and they will be
joining myself professor karkarov
and madame maxine on the panel that will
judge the champion's efforts
after the 94 tournament took place most
of these people died which would have
made the organization of feature
tournaments
improbable in addition to all of this
continuing the tournament would have
almost been
insensitive so much went wrong in the
tournament of 1994
and provided that it was now associated
with voldemort's resurgence
it was almost tainted what do you guys
think
did it continue after 1994 let me know
in the comment section
below until next time until such time
you remain
in the eyes of the ministry a convicted
death eater
you